you grew up South Central LA grew up
kind of a tough neighborhood yeah yeah
pretty tough yeah
did you yeah when was the first time at
what age do you realize you can kind of
take care of yourself if you were in a
situation
you mean fighting yeah oh man no I meant
yeah I meant see boss yeah yeah hey
mother show and go yeah I was about six
seven about seven yeah I just dude kept
kicking over my bike you know when you
about seven your bike is your car you
know I mean so he kept kicking it over
and I didn't want to fight him cuz he
was eight and when you said it you think
cuz he's a beach I'm a different it is
between seven and eight is big number
telling my other friend like man he ate
I can't I can't win I can't win yeah and
so he just kicked it over one too many
times and then I just I worked him beat
that ass man
[Applause]
I was like Popeye that's all I could
stand I can't stands no more
I just love you quoting Popeye so that's
when you knew you knew like you get push
this you know I'm the same way you know
you pushed me too far
then these hands come out you know what
I'm saying I don't know about that I
think you need to join like a Fight Club
you think I should be in a Fight Club
yeah so you can get your ass whooped you
know it could be a you know common time
control how many times do you think I
need to be beat before I'll get some
sense kicked into me Oh times in a long
process yeah yeah it'll all come to me
pretty quickly as well yeah yeah yes I
got beat once I got beat up once yeah
that's once was enough
I learned my lesson okay and do you know
this story is you know like 18 years old
now I was in Boston and ran into a gang
of kids and they wanted $0.50 and I'd
told him no they wanted 50 cents they
punched my face in they completely
punched it in okay yeah so that does not
give me some street cred with you cube
none beat up gives you have to fight
back - yes oh okay well no screw that
that's not happening
you